i
cómo
rusia ha dicho que quiere mantener
vínculos de amistad con países amigos de
la unión europea pero ha puntualizado
que ahora mismo las relaciones con las
instituciones comunitarias con las
instituciones de la web son un cadáver
un cuerpo muerto el ministro de asuntos
exteriores ruso serguéi lávrov ha
puntualizado que la unión europea y
europa son dos conceptos distintos y que
ellos no piensan irse de europa los
rusos ya es el segundo aviso la semana
pasada el propio lávrov había adelantado
que están preparados para romper
relaciones con la unión europea así
desde las instituciones comunitarias
desde bruselas se impulsan nuevas
sanciones contra rusia que puedan
afectar a sectores sensibles de su
economía ese encontronazo se producía
poco después de la polémica entre lávrov
y el jefe de la diplomacia europea josep
borrell que recientemente sugirió la
posibilidad de poner en marcha nuevas
sanciones contra rusia después del
encarcelamiento del opositor
alexéi navalni
[Música]
las relaciones entre la unión europea y
rusia han estado marcadas en los últimos
años por las tensiones el reciente viaje
del jefe de la diplomacia europea
susan murray a moscú no ha calmado las
aguas el envenenamiento y también
encarcelación del líder opositor alexéi
navalni ha sido la gota que ha colmado
el vaso en unas relaciones que llevan
desde una década con problemas
especialmente por la participación de
rusia en la guerra del este de ucrania
también por inscribirse en procesos
electorales como en el de belarús
también por influir también en las
guerras de libia siria también nagorno
karabaj o tratar de dividir a la unión
europea difundiendo noticias falsas en
definitiva por todas estas razones la
unión europea ha aplicado sanciones a
altos cargos del gobierno no se
descartan otras y más aún cuando
coincidiendo con el viaje de eso se
aburren a moscú se expulsaron a tres
diplomáticos europeos los jefes de
estado y de gobierno de la unión europea
discutirán en su próxima reunión
relaciones con rusia que ahora mismo
están en uno de sus peores momentos
[Música]
el tono de eeuu frente a rusia ha
cambiado y desde el 4 de febrero cuando
yo badén dio su primer discurso en temas
internacionales dijo que su
administración hará un reinicio de las
relaciones internacionales
esto incluye entre otras cosas volver al
multilateralismo y trabajar de cerca con
la organización del tratado del
atlántico norte que se formó para
contrarrestar la influencia y el
crecimiento militar ruso tras la segunda
guerra mundial
bailén también ha dicho expresamente que
hará responsable a putin por los
ciberataques y la interferencia
electoral en eeuu además pidió la
liberación del líder opositor alexéi
navalni arrestado por destapar
escándalos de corrupción en rusia a
pesar de esto los dos países firmaron
una extensión de cinco años del acuerdo
start que pone límites al arsenal
nuclear de los dos países
[Música]